hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll for
many reasons in recent years the world
has seen stress being placed on its
governments the notion of democratic
governance in particular and there's
polarization that makes people on
different sides of political issues
really turn against each other really
think of other people other citizens
within their country as the enemy rather
than as someone they have to learn to
get along with and maybe that's
justified in some cases maybe it's not
but it's hard to have a flourishing
long-lasting Community Democratic
community in a country or in a society
that is like that where people don't
trust each other or even think that
other people are fundamentally on the
same side despite their disagreements So
today we're talking to Margaret Levy who
is a very accomplished political
scientist and someone who has thought a
lot of about the question of what makes
a government legitimate
we'd like to think that the people in a
democracy are what legitimates the
authority of the government but as a
matter of fact our government is usually
there when we're born right the
government's already there it's an
institution most people do not
participate in the setting up of the
government that they are ultimately
subject to so what is the theoretical
justification for saying that the
government has any right to have the
power over it us that it does why do
people for the most part voluntarily
hand over authority to the state either
historically or philosophically and so
Marcus done a lot of work on this she's
written some wonderful books about it
and comes to a set of conclusions that I
think are are both really important but
also they seem almost you know Charming
in some sense like oh yeah sure I wish
it were that nice but nevertheless this
is a case where that's the way to go I
think and and what she emphasizes
especially is the need for people in the
community to under the same kind of
government to think of themselves as
sharing a fate a community of Fate
whether or not you agree with someone
else in your country about a certain
political
policy or not we still are going to live
in the same country we are still going
to flourish or suffer depending on how
we do as a society as a whole and we
have to take that fact into account when
we think about how to make a government
and how that government should behave
and a huge role is played by the idea of
trust the idea that we can actually
trust our governments to at least try to
do the right thing to be responsible to
our needs things like that institutions
are sometimes trustworthy and sometimes
not and again it can see almost hopeful
and overly optimistic and naive to even
talk about trust in government at a time
like this but that doesn't make it any
less important and finally an important
role here is played by the idea of
empathy and understanding that their
your Fates are intertwined with people
who are very far away people who might
not be like you people who you don't run
into all the time but in our
interconnected World our Collective
faiths are going to rise and fall
together so this is both kind of a
descriptive question of how government
actually does work and a prescriptive
question of how we should try to make
things better so Market is extremely
eloquent talking about these things and
is thought about them very deeply this
is one of those things you know unlike
talking about black hole thermodynamics
this is something where we've all
thought about it a little bit we all
have opinions so it's nice to talk to
someone who is a true expert and with
that let's go
[Music]
thank you
Margaret Levy welcome to the mindscape
podcast well thank you nice to be here
Sean I thought that uh you know you've
had a long and and very productive
career talking about really big
questions uh that cross political
science and even some you know political
philosophy and and other kinds of social
science I thought I found a sentence
that you wrote in a
quasi-autobiographical article in annual
reviews that I thought just reading it
out loud we could probably base the
whole podcast on this one sentence but
you know understanding what goes into it
but let me read it for the audience
this is you speaking my commitment to
combining normative concerns with
empirical social science LED perhaps a
bit counter-intuitively to early
adoption of rational Choice political
economy
so on the one hand that's pretty
straightforward and and but it packs a
lot in so I thought I would you know ask
you to elaborate on some little bits of
it starting with
what do you mean by combining normative
concerns what do you mean by normative
concerns what are the kinds of concerns
you have in mind when you say that
oh there are a whole uh long list of
them but uh we'll start with something
I'm working on right now which has to do
with political equality
um I'm writing a book with Tim besley in
London and Pablo baramendi at Duke on
trying to understand the concept of
political equality and what it means to
live in a community of equals so our we
have a normative goal we would actually
like to make the world more politically
equal at least the Democratic world and
live up to its help it live up to its
aspirations but in order to do that you
don't start with a set of the principles
you want to achieve you really have to
understand how the world is working
um what's going on what's blocking
things
um what's facilitating certain kinds of
goals where the trade-offs are and those
are deeply empirical questions sure so
my work on trust my work on citizenship
all of that work is motivated related
by Deep deeply held ethical and
normative commitments but in order to
create an understanding of how we might
achieve those ends requires at least for
me some in-depth research
about how those processes actually work
well when you just say the phrase
political equality this is one of those
things that maybe sounds good but I know
from
talking to people in the real world I
also had Elizabeth Anderson on the
podcast sometimes yeah yeah and uh
fabulous and there are people out there
who don't like equality who think that
it's a code word for making sure that
everyone has exactly the same amount of
wealth or something like that so you put
political in there what do you mean by
political equality
well when people are talking about
economic equality they're generally
talking about distributional issues
achieved through a variety of means but
they mean evening out the income and the
wealth to some extent different people
have different levels of what that
extent means
when you talk about political equality
you're talking about there may or may
not be economic inequality but when
there is economic inequality which there
almost always is it clearly has some
effect on uh who has voice and how they
can express it so what you want to do
politically is create institutional
Arrangements that delimit how much that
economic equal inequality can impact the
political inequality but it isn't just
about the interaction between the
economic and the political so Elizabeth
Anderson is a great segue here because
um I've been very influenced by her work
on relational equality and by Daniel
Allen's work as well which is a little
different but is getting at the same set
of issues about ensuring that when we
talk about equal consideration we mean
that people are given
um relatively equal and I always use the
word relatively because it's never
perfect
relatively equal respect and dignity and
that their voices are seriously taken
into account
and that is very different than economic
inequality or equality which is it can
be measured by wealth or income and
somehow it always surprises me that
people are not more outraged by
political inequality as you've just
defined it I mean economic inequality
there's a story that says everyone
strives to be rich and they think that
eventually they will be rich so they're
happy that rich people exist now but why
aren't more people really upset maybe
this goes into the empirical side of
things why aren't people more outraged
that economic inequality feeds so
strongly into the size of voice you have
in the political system
that is an empirical puzzle
and one of the ones we're trying to
resolve that's you know I'm outraged
sounds like your instinct is to be
outraged but in fact a lot of people
could care less I mean how deeply held
is democracy as a value and what do
people mean by democracy do they even
mean political equality or equal
consideration so some people just mean
you have a constitution that says one
person one vote and you don't get in the
way of it too much but if you get in a
way of it a little bit that's okay
um other people don't seem to value that
at all and yet think they value
democracy so it's it's a complex
empirical puzzle I think
um the other piece of it is that um
when you think about political equality
there is no no perfect set there's no
perfect equilibrium outcome there are a
lot of trade-offs here so you improve
the suffrage I mean this is back to the
old problem that John Stuart Mill raised
you improve the subject the suffrage if
you don't improve the education do you
get a worse electorate
um and what it what what are you trading
off for getting the work a worse
electorate even though you're giving
everybody equal voice
so I think you got to really think
deeply about what the actual trade-offs
are and face up to that and that might
help you get at some of these underlying
reasons
um even if people won't say them out
loud why they don't value political
equality well good see like you said
right there in the sentence that I read
at the start uh empirical social science
is an important part of how you do these
things so what does that mean for the
people out there who are you know young
protophysicists or whatever have no idea
what it means to do empirical social
science like are you out there doing
experiments on people or what's going on
personally I am not out there doing
experiments on people though I have no
problem with those who are engaging in
various kinds of experimental research
it means drawing on whatever tools and
approaches are best for answering the
question that you have at hand and given
the complexity of the world and the
complexity of our skill sets you might
notice in my CV that I do an awful lot
of collaboration and a lot of
co-authoring because very few of us have
all the skills you need too
do the work so for example in the
politically quality book
um Tim besley is a very distinguished
econometrician now I can sort of read
what he does
um and I can read but I can't do the
kinds of sophisticated statistics that
he does and yet I value them and see
that they really play an important role
um
so
I think it really depends on what the
question is and then making sure that
you have the right people and skill set
there to help you answer the question a
lot of my work is actually archival
historical interview work
um
my own personal work or deep reading uh
you know pulling out of work that's at
research that's already been done and
synthesizing it in a new way those are
that is still doing Empirical research
but it's different set of skill sets
than collecting statistics or doing
experiments the bringing up of
collaboration is interesting because I'm
completely on board I almost always
collaborate myself uh I'm now
technically a member of the philosophy
Department faculty at Johns Hopkins and
we just had a meeting on to what extent
we should let our graduate students
collaborate on papers that will end up
as part of their dissertations for the
for the PHD yeah philosophers just
aren't used to this yet so the more
interdisciplinary ones in the room raise
their hands and say we've got to let our
students collaborate because you know
we're not trying to train them to be
neuroscientists or physicists or
whatever but we want them to talk to
those people
that's right I'm I'm totally on board
with that but I do see that that's a
continuing problem in virtually every
field except for some of the Sciences
which are used to collaboration
okay so then you say that this
combination of normative concerns and
empirical social science leads you
perhaps a bit counter-intuitively to
rational Choice political economy so
number one what do you mean by rational
Choice political economy and number two
why is it counter-intuitive that you'd
be led there
um rash so rash let's start with what it
is uh rational Choice uh political
economy is using the tools of basically
economics uh microeconomics largely and
the kind of reasoning that goes into
microeconomics and applying it to
political problems and making the
assumptions uh that we no longer make by
the way I no longer consider myself
practicing I never practice traditional
rational choice and even I'm even
farther from it now but it certainly was
an important part of my career so that's
why it appears in the autobiographical
essay but rational choices really makes
the assumption that people are largely
rational
that they have a sense a clear sense of
what their preferences are those
preferences are transitive if you prefer
a to B and B to C you're going to prefer
a to c
um and B just you know and not prefer C
to B
um
so that that it makes certain
assumptions about a kind of rationality
in the narrowest uh version and it's
kind of decision theoretic yes and in
the narrowest version of it it makes the
assumption that individuals are narrowly
self-interested
that their their objectives really have
to do with
um material and narrow largely material
and certainly narrow interests they may
include the family but doesn't
necessarily even have to go that far so
it's a very individualist approach
power however its limits are already
obvious in what I've said that its
assumptions are relatively unrealistic
and it's individualistic as opposed to
thinking about networks or interactions
or the interactions only come from
thinking about the individual and not
interactions that are created by a group
those are limits that I confronted early
on
but it also um has some power
it's parsimonious
it's rigorous
when used with certain kinds of gain
Theory
it lays out a way of thinking about the
world that tells you that this is likely
to happen
and gives you reasons why things might
not have happened
or have happened
and if you can't find those reasons in
the world
than something you can you can actually
debunk your theory which is very hard to
do as we know sure
so it won it uh it provided at least
initially for me a form of discipline on
doing
historical or ethnographic work where
what what details are essential to the
story and which are not how do I make
that determination
and it also uh gave me a way to think
about okay if this detail exists if this
thing happened in the world
it shouldn't then the outcome shouldn't
have been X it should have been Y and
yet the outcome in this historical event
or this particular
place was why
so
um it was a great way to emerge from
what I had learned
which was
very fuzzy I have to say until I learned
about some of this kind of thinking I
mean I I read great people I learned a
lot I went to good universities I mean I
have I have no complaint about my
education but I didn't have
I couldn't find the right method for the
kind of work that I was trying to do so
that's what rational choices and why it
was important to me why was it
counter-intuitive because rational
Choice was really identified with what
we now call neoliberalism what was
called public choice and represents a
kind of there's a bias many people
believe is in it I don't believe it need
be in it but many people do believe
isn't it that leads it to be
conservative or to have a vision of the
world and a set of values that I don't
share I'm not an individualist in that
particular way but that's part of what
rational Choice means to a lot of people
so I'll just give you a story to
illustrate uh the implication of that so
I went on my first sabbatical and came
back and almost no one had no graduate
students except for three who I had
known before had signed up for my
graduate class
which was unusual I have to say for me I
was a fairly popular teacher so I asked
him what was going on they said well the
rumor spread around that your rational
choice and therefore deeply conservative
and I said what you know that I'm
probably the most radical person in the
department they said we know that we
tried to tell them but they said no
she's rational Choice rational dismiss
it
which only ensconcs me more in it
because I don't like being dismissed on
the grounds of something people don't
understand
so that created a mission at the
University of Washington which I
fulfilled ultimately so is it possible
you know in a small number of words to
explain why rational Choice wouldn't be
right I mean and you you sort of defined
it kind of narrowly but couldn't we just
expand the definition of rationality a
little bit and even if from the
outsider's point of view someone who's
acting irrationally maybe from their
perspective given their values could we
figure out a way in which they're acting
rationally or is that just not the right
way to go in some big picture way well
that's how I started in fact that was is
what I did so I brought ethics in an
ethical considerations uh as part of the
preference set of people and that those
Norms that people were that were guiding
people and affected their preferences
were in fact often socially constituted
not just individually constituted they
came from a particular culture and
context which was another important
piece of the puzzle for me so again let
me make that concrete
one of the pieces of research I did was
on conscription and volunteering for
military service across six countries
five Anglo-Saxon democracies in France
over 200 years basically the history of
conscription and volunteering for
military service as opposed to being
impressed only into military service
and one of the most interesting case
studies was of the francophones in
Canada versus the anglophones in Canada
who had very different reactions to the
first world war and the Second World War
and in the anglophone case they thought
rah-rah to the two World Wars Britain's
under attack we have to defend Britain
that means Canada is under attack
because we're a Dominion the francophone
said
wait a minute our constitution for
Canada and the Confederation principles
say that we only have to be at War if
Canada itself is under attack not the
empire
and beside and they said well what about
the French don't you identify with the
French the French are under attack they
said the French left us on the ice flows
in the 17th century and then had a
revolution and changed their their
religion we don't care about the French
and they make fun of us when we come to
parrots because of our accents all true
so all true right I'm of course
characterizing charactering the
situation but but what was going on was
two very different cultures had emerged
with very different views about how the
central government was treating them the
francophones felt very neglected many
promises had not been kept about quality
of education and quality of treatment
and a whole variety of other things the
anglophones at least the Ontario
angophones felt uh very
good with the government it was very
much their government
so one the francophones did not
volunteer for military service whereas
the anglophones did at a very high rate
and when conscription came up for a vote
the francophones voted it down and the
anglophones voted it up the votes were
like totally different and this was in
two different world wars the same thing
repeated itself in the Second World War
so
um you know that was a case where they
were both acting rationally
given their preferences but they had
different ethical
maximans as well as interest maximums in
fact if you were only going by narrow
economic interest you would have
expected the francophones who were
poorer than the anglophones to sign up
at a higher rate because it was a job
during a depression we were talking
about the Second World War
so um you know that was that was where I
used rational choice
and I could in fact do some Game Theory
I could I could uh lay out a whole set
of
counterfactuals as well as uh some
alternative uh hypotheses that were
derived from the rational Choice model
but I had different Maxim ants in there
or different preference rankings and
different preferences than the normal
economists doing rational choice or even
the normal political Economist doing
rational choice and so this sounds very
sensible in that a real person real
human beings don't just maximize their
average income or expected income or
something like that they have other
values that they care about and they
want to maximize their allegiance to
those values but then I think you're
hinting that at the end of the day you
just don't think that the rational
Choice theory is the right way to go
even in that expanded sense
well I think there's still some value to
some of it just as there's lots of value
to economics I mean I'm not throwing the
baby out with the dishwater but one of
the things that happened during the
course of my academic career was
condiment and diversky
um and a whole lot of other research
that's followed from that which has just
raised questions about the kind of
rationality we use and where our biases
come from and what are the sources of
our beliefs that really has to be
brought in and so the story rational
choice is great because it's simple and
parsimonious
and so there's still some ways I want to
use it but in order to fully explain the
differences because of context because
of individual differences because of
group biases you need more than rational
Choice can provide and that has created
a whole new frontier for those of us who
are trying to combine some form of
parsimonious Theory you just spoke with
Henry Farrell he's another one within
this Camp
who is very committed to trying to think
about parsimony and rigor but also very
committed to having the right kind of
level of complexity in the understanding
of the world and bringing context in
institutions in the rational Choice
World initially was institution free
um
this is all individuals and so that that
changed that changed too with the North
and other the new economic
institutionalists began to bring that in
and I was very much part of that so we
were bringing institutions in but before
you knew it we had
it wasn't rational Choice anymore it was
something
um and we're still it's a kind of
political economy and we're still
struggling to make it really work you
know it reminds me of yet another
podcast interview I did with t Nguyen
who is a philosopher who actually
studies the philosophy of games and
gaming like literal Video Games Etc and
then extends that to gamification and
argues that the clarity of rules and
rewards in a game is what makes them so
seductive and attractive and also
ultimately what leads people to
conspiracy theories you know very simple
models that explain everything in the
world and maybe in a much milder form I
don't want to get in trouble here but
maybe that's the kind of reason why
academics might be attracted to rational
Choice Theory right it's simple it seems
rigorous you can make predictions might
not always be right but it has that
level of rigor to which we aspire
right and and you know for certain kinds
of problems it can be right right
it's just that it itself it selects the
problems
and if you're interested in problems
that aren't amenable to that particular
method and I often am like political
equality
um you know where you can use bits of
rational choice but it's only going to
get you so far right okay let's go back
to the French uh French Canadians and
anglo-canadians
um and their differential responses to
the draft because this is also an
example not only of the modeling
failures or successes but of the bigger
project that you've been involved with
is trying to understand
why citizens or people in society give
their allegiance to a government right
why they give their Authority their
rights to make decisions over themselves
to some form of government so again
maybe I don't know if you have a short
answer to that question that sounds like
a very complicated one but we can dig
into it more uh broadly what is it that
makes a person say yes I will let this
government make up rule tools then
inflict them upon me
well I think there are a couple things
and
um and this predates democracies
because we've seen this happen in all
kinds of regimes
um where I don't think people are being
brainwashed I feel like they are
actually giving seeding authority to
government
and what generally does it is uh and
this can be very simple I mean simple in
statement not simple in practice let me
put it that way they perceive the
government as trustworthy
that is
they believe that the government has
made some promises to them that it is
likely to keep
and seems to be keeping
they're often but not always economic
promises
um they they can be about security and
but they're in that material bucket
generally
um including National Security
that can be part of the as it were
contract with the citizens
um so the first thing is that they
perceive the government will provide
things and will actually deliver on them
uh two uh they believe that the process
by which government is handing out the
goods and making the decisions who will
get the goods meet standards of fairness
of the day and time and place
so they're not seeing their next door
neighbor because she's young and
beautiful getting all the perks
uh or their obese male neighbor getting
all the perks because he owns the
brewery
um you know whatever it is uh that that
in fact
by the standards of the day which
obviously vary
and finally and in many ways this is
I guess the thing that I brought into
the story that not everybody had seen
before which is that there is confidence
that government will catch and punish
the Free Riders
okay so those who don't accede to the
authority and try to rip off the system
in one way or another
even though they're getting the benefits
of the system
will be punished by that the government
has the competence and capacity to
deliver the goods as well as to locate
and punish those who are free riding so
that makes for a trustworthy government
and when people perceive a government
and I'm using the word perceive here
because it's not totally factual I mean
there's a perceptual element as we're
seeing right now in the United States
strong perceptual element that can be
influenced by other factors then reality
um
but when they perceive the government as
trustworthy they're more willing to
willingly comply or consent with its
extractive demands and it sounds like
there's an I don't know equal but at
least very big emphasis both on having
trust that the government is trying to
be fair uh but then also the government
is competent that the government is
actually relatively successful
that's right so competence and fairness
are both critical elements here and is
this something that is either especially
or almost exclusively true for the
founding generation of whatever
governmental form we have or is it kind
of a constant renegotiation between the
constant renegotiation constant
renegotiation so the government's job is
to convince the citizens that it is
trustworthy at all times
so one of the cases that I researched
was a tax case in Australia
where the tax system had really gone
awry not this is not an unusual problem
this was in Democratic Australia I mean
it's not an unusual problem around the
world that the tax system goes awry for
a variety of reasons but this was
particularly egregious so certain
um very certain well-off people could
find tax loopholes and they were just
getting benefits through the Gazoo
and part of why that happened was
because it's going to sound like a
familiar story
um part of why that happened was the man
who became the Supreme Court Justice had
been a tax lawyer and he had failed to
win some of these cases that made things
loopholes so he had the cases brought up
again and this time they went through
but think about workers whose taxes are
taken out as they earn right they don't
have a choice about loopholes and all
the rest of that and the Australian
system is fairly simple so there aren't
a lot of deductions and stuff
so what happened was a tax revolt
and a political revolt
um because it was hard to have a tax
revolt but you could have a political
revolt and the government was voted out
and the hawk government was voted in a
labor party government and Hawk
confronted the situation where the the
tax system was totally distrusted by a
huge proportion of the population and
particularly his constituents
and so he basically called a new
Constitutional Convention now some of
that was smoke and mirrors but the idea
was to rethink the tax system bring
everybody into it rewrite it say we're
starting again
now that's well after the founding we're
talking in the
1990s okay Australia began in 1900
um not a lot of people left from that
rounding Moment by 1994 if they were
they weren't very effective in
government yeah and they'd been babies
when you know it had started
um so it was really a new generation
creating a new as it were fiscal
contract uh with the population is there
some this is the physicist we saw that
with the new deal I mean that's part of
what the New Deal was in principle about
right in the U.S this is this is the
physicist inside me talking but is there
some sense in in which you know pressure
builds up and you know the government
sort of
accumulates uh deviation from
trustworthiness and then some kind of
Revolt happens either Financial or
political or something like that the
government has to correct itself and if
it goes too far then we're in trouble
sometimes and sometimes it's sometimes
that's the form it takes for sure and
sometimes it's a big rupture
so
I mean I think of recent history in the
U.S I mean I found Trump a big rupture
with what I understood government was
supposed to be doing and a big rupture
in a way that I mean I didn't like many
of both Bush's policies but I didn't
find them a rupture from my
understanding of how government was
supposed to work I just disagreed with
the policies
the different problem
where does the difference come from I
mean I I get also there is a difference
so is it a symptom of a pre-existing
loss of trust or is it causing the loss
of trust
well I think it can be both I mean I I
think this is a complexity problem yeah
so I mean I think of course there's some
build up in either case because there's
popular pressure that leads to a trump
um but
the actual break is very sudden as
opposed I mean there can be very gradual
changes that may not be an effect of
pressure at all
um it may simply be that you keep
tweaking with something I'll give you
another example of that
um in the United States we have the
National Labor Relations Act which was
passed in the 19 mid 1930s
it's still the law governing
um labor today you know how unions can
form and what counts as a strike and how
you appeal when an employer or a labor
union is abusing its power or the law
but you know we're now almost 100 years
later
so that's a law that has gotten a little
bit of tweak a little bit of tweak
mostly in the administrative law side
not the big Congressional law side
and so you now you have a system that
barely works at all
right so it's a different kind of build
up of problem than the buildup of
popular pressure about being unhappy
about something
where you finally get something that
just isn't working
and everybody recognizes it but doing
something about it isn't always so easy
and it again my physicists had talking
it seems like a manifestation of the
second law of Thermodynamics that
entropy increases and Things become
Messier and more broken and it doesn't
seem like there's an obvious
acknowledgment of that in governments as
far as I know that over time systems
will get less and less responsive so we
have to replace them is there do we have
a predictive theory for that kind of
behavior
well I'm trying now of course because
you put me on the spot to think of the
people who who've written like that but
there certainly are people who made that
argument whether they use this the
second law of physics
I'm not sure
um but certainly people think along
those lines
okay so going back to like the the trust
that that the people have in the
government uh you correct me if I'm
wrong because I've always had this sort
of folk Theory and you know much more
about this than I do but in the 1990s
when Newt Gingrich was in charge of the
Republican Congress and so forth it
seemed to me that there was a shift
where
people in Congress real like they did
the game theory calculation and they
realized that if what they wanted was to
maximize their chance of winning office
they would behave differently than if
what they wanted was to maximize some
particular policy preference outcomes
and in particular negotiating with the
other side is always bad even if it
leads to a policy that you like and
since then that's made it a lot harder
for the government to get things done is
this just a figment of my imagination or
is there some correlation with reality
there you think
I think there's a correlation with
reality but I think it would be mistaken
to think that that's the only time
that's happened in the history of the
United States or other democracies
you know I think that they're the way in
which you might recall that the founding
and they were all fathers
um conceived uh were very nervous about
political parties because they would
lead to this kind of competition and
lead to this kind of
view of interest and they were worried
about factions even though they started
with them and continued with them and
had to have a war one of the biggest
ones right
um so you know that's been a constant
tension really
because there are some issues the ques
that and periodically you get to a point
and this happened before the Civil War
and it's happened again now and it's
happened at other moments in other
democracies where you get to a point
where some of the leadership just will
not compromise compromise goes out the
the
window and then you get to a place where
the country's ungovernable because
democratic government most governments
frankly are based on some form of
negotiation and bargaining and you give
up something and you get back something
I actually think one of the worst things
that happened in Congress was when it
gave up
um
I'm blocking the word for it but uh the
side benefits you get the poor oh yeah
right when it gave up barreling earmarks
I mean there were well they're now
called earmarks when I was growing up
they were called Pork barreling
um I know what earmarks are they're the
same thing
but it's basically you know a way in
which you can create traits
I mean now that doesn't mean that all
the Pork barreling and all the earmarks
are good and they certainly are
expensive but are they more expensive
than not getting to any kind of
agreement at all
and it's an occasional Bridge to Nowhere
the worst thing that could happen to us
yeah no that's actually I mean is that a
that seems perfectly sensible to me when
you put it that way I think that the the
naive view is
pork barrel politics is corrupt and it's
just buying votes Etc but if you cast it
as the price you have to pay to get
things done then maybe it's worth the
cost is that a
consensus view among political
scientists or is that something that is
not it's a view I don't know is there a
conductor political scientist no not
about anything
but
but that certainly is a view I mean I'm
I'm not the only one to have said that
no and even think about you know you
think about
[Music]
um
what you were so
even even if you're not in the Gingrich
world and refusing to compromise you
almost all Congress people and senators
are in the world where they have to
worry about pleasing their constituents
or they can't to some extent
or they can't be re-elected now
occasionally someone will take a very
principled stand as we recently saw
um and she loses big yeah
um in her home state right
but mostly people have to pay attention
to what their constituents believe they
need or bring home some pork
to the constituents and that's not
necessarily leading to lack of
compromise it can actually enhance
compromise in those kinds of situations
and that's recognizing the reality
that Representatives have two roles to
play and we haven't figured out how to
enhance their ability to play both at
once one is to deliver to their
constituents to act actually represent
those who elected them
and the other is to resent represent the
whole polity bringing the voice of their
constituents into the wisdom of the
crowds
and is there any way that you've noticed
historically from other times when trust
in government has broken down that we
can recover from that are there things
the government successfully do to get
working again uh I mean I guess there's
two hidden questions I'm trying to ask
it once one is this is there a way to
get people in the government
compromising and being effective at
passing legislation again and number two
is are there ways to get people to think
that the government is fighting for them
yeah two very different questions so the
first question the most effective way to
get people to work together is a war
uh not too bad
yeah
um I mean when you look at the
historical record the times when
countries really pull together and
overcome those partisan and sectarian
differences is often when they're under
threat now the threat need not be a war
it has generally been a war it could be
climate change I mean I keep hoping that
the environmental crisis we're facing
might evoke that so far it hasn't it
could be covet it didn't do it but my
prediction at the beginning my wrong
prediction was that it would have
um that here was a common threat we were
all facing where a solution had to be
fine found and in the meantime we had to
work together to protect each other and
ourselves
um but in principle those kinds of EX
those kinds of threats
um
should have or can have and in some
countries they did Taiwan they did
um not just because it was small just
but because it managed that the threat
of covid in a very different way so it
can under certain circumstances
institutional and Leadership
circumstances have that kind of
consequence I'm not asking for threats
yeah but I'm just recognizing
empirically that that's a major way in
which it happens
you know a more benignly
um
it's really I mean I think this is what
Biden and other leaders have been trying
to do uh
right and left
is to really try to clarify to the
public what's at stake right now and how
we have to be engaged in a common
purpose if we're going to ensure that
the United States be a peaceful healthy
Growing Place that can encourage
flourishing of most of its population
those attempts have seldom totally
succeeded but they're not they do get
some distance I mean
bind's done a remarkable job I think in
the last
less than a year certainly not at the
beginning but now in this past year and
getting things passed and part of that
is recognizing the art of compromise
but okay I'm gonna I'm gonna put forward
a pessimistic take here that maybe
you'll just go along with maybe you'll
refute I'm not sure but like you say we
could have predicted that something like
covid or maybe something ongoing like uh
also ongoing like climate change is a
common threat that would bring us
together
but in some very real sense that is not
happening uh because in some very real
sense the information ecosystem is
making it the case that there are no
more common threats no matter how bad a
threat is it will be politicized and
polarized and that might be one of the
signs that our society is just breaking
down in that sense is that something
that I should really take seriously
yes okay
that's right I mean it could be I'm
hoping it's not I'm hoping they're ways
out of this
um you know and to say that the
um information ecosystem yes it's faster
it's more intense now
but newspapers used to do that they were
different newspapers for different
publics radio stations did that
um
television does that I mean we're not
just talking about the digital media
here uh so it's been an ongoing I mean
the the printing press did that you know
just having access to different sources
of information controlled by not just
the church or the state
um as soon as that was opened up
um you were going to begin to have some
of these kinds of conflicts
so the question really is
um not that they're going to exist or
that they're going to happen again
but how do we overcome them when they do
how do we create some common sense of
understanding at least around some key
facts
and I think that's the really tough
question that social scientists are
facing today right uh this this period
has really revealed
uh How Deeply held false beliefs can be
impermeable to the kinds of things that
we thought information was permeable to
and I guess that is one very big worry
simply false beliefs at a at a factual
empirical level but the other big worry
is uh this
no longer thinking of ourselves as part
of a common
future a common uh Society right I mean
there's people on both sides are talking
about Civil War and or dividing the
country up or something like that and
maybe this is also true outside the U.S
I'm just not as familiar it is true
outside the U.S yeah yeah and the look
of Scotland isn't sure it wants to be
part of Britain it hasn't for a long
time but it's right becoming
and Catalonia doesn't want to be part of
Spain I mean the UK didn't want to be
part of Europe right right and so all
right that sounds like a tough challenge
for democracy like I always like to say
that democracy is not about you vote and
the winner gets their choice but you
vote and the loser has to put up with
the Winner's Choice and and we seem
increasingly unwilling to go along with
that philosophy
I think that's right but there are there
are a couple of ways possibly out of
that dilemma one is to really as many
people are right now really look deeply
at what we mean by democracy and how
it's being practiced and
um see if that's encouraging this kind
of splintering as opposed to overcoming
this kind of splintering and how we can
fix that
another is to think of democracy itself
as an experiment
that may have reached its limits
and I'm not saying we go to autocracy
there may be authoritarianism but there
may be other ways in which we can
self-govern
that are different than what we've
inherited in so many countries from the
past that maybe this particular kind of
system just no longer works for the
kinds of complexities of the world today
I don't have that alternative in mind I
lots of people are engaging in
experiments and thinking about that
and you know I'm focused on the first
about how we can fix the Democracy that
we have
but I'm open to the second as a real
possibility because it may be that this
is unfixable and then we better have
people out there really being
imaginative and thinking about what do
we put in its place well that's as
opposed to a you know a a terrible
leader who is
[Music]
um
you know we don't want demagoguery so uh
we've got to find an alternative at some
point so just to get us thinking because
this is a fascinating idea that I'm not
very familiar with I mean what kind of
Alternatives might there be even if
they're bad and we haven't hit on the
right one yet that would be sort of not
autocratic but not a democracy either
and yet let people ultimately be giving
authority to the state that is governing
them
well they're not democracy in the sense
in which we have practiced
representative democracy so they may
still have be Democratic okay
um
for example there are a lot of
experiments going on with elections by
Lottery and large numbers of people and
you know you just get picked like you
get picked for the draft and you have to
go serve for two years in the
legislature and you're just a normal
person
um
laughs and you have to learn things and
you have to realize where expertise is
useful and where it's not and you know
that but there are a lot of experiments
going on with that kind of thing there
are experiments going on with uh public
bargaining I mean public budgeting
um where certain parts of the budget uh
are subject to a very Democratic public
process in the community where that
budget is going to have an effect
uh
those are a couple of the experiments
that are going on there are things going
on using uh digital tools that give
people voice in a variety of ways uh
there's some cyber
experiments I mean there are all kinds
of things that are happening that I
think are worth really paying radical
exchange is an organization that has
encouraged a lot of different
experiments
um Ellen landemore who is a philosopher
at Yale has written about a variety of
ways in which constitutions and other
kinds of policies can be made in a much
more public way engaging many more
people I'm just citing two concrete
people organizations
who've thought about changing changing
the processes of voting in very radical
ways as as Glenn Weil has advocated and
and uh
yeah as others have advocated you know I
once I mean those are all worth
considering I I'm not advocating any of
them I guess
I I once on Twitter half tongue-in-cheek
suggested that if a wealthy person runs
for national office they have to give up
almost all their wealth if they win
the idea being that it would really be
if you wanted to be a public servant you
would really be doing it for the sake of
being a public servant uh right and I I
it was
one of the things I put on Twitter
occasionally that just was universally
condemned people thought that I was
completely not so for saying that like
you know how dare you exclude the best
and brightest from serving their country
which maybe goes back to the
equality discussion that we started with
but you know it's yet another maybe
tweak I would say on the process of
democracy rather than giving up on
Democracy altogether that's right so
there are three possibilities here right
there's one fixing the Democracy we have
two finding some fairly radical
changes to the kind of democracy we have
the lottery systems or the
um some of these voting systems are not
like anything we've ever practiced
before or anybody's ever practiced
except in very small communities maybe
in ancient Greece
um
or really finding a serious alternative
to democracy
there are people and I think all those
are on the table there are people who
want a constitutional convention but
that scares The Living Daylights out of
me to imagine what would actually come
out of such a thing I mean this goes
back to the trust that we have in our
fellow citizens uh I'm kind even though
I think that the current system is not
great I worry about realistic changes to
it making things much worse
well here's where institutions can
create the trust
I'm not saying and it's not easy to do
so again it's not like oh here's a
simple solution let me just write you a
prescription dear and you'll be fine
um
but go to go back to that case of Hawk
and the kind of Constitutional
Convention that he created around the
the tax law what he did was set up a set
of Arrangements that people had real
confidence in that their voices would be
heard even though they were disparate
voices that they would be heard that
they would be respected that they
actually had a chance of making a
difference
um and created a circumstance in which
people could argue civilly
and enforce that so that's a set of
institutional Arrangements that then
create confidence that you can go into
that forum
and be treated with respect and not be
allowed to act in a way
now that's not easy to do particularly
in a world I mean that was a conflictual
world this is an even more conflictual
world the one we're in right now with
with real antagonisms and anger of a
level that is
um something I have seldom experienced
in my lifetime I've seen it I mean I
lived through McCarthyism I lived
through the war in Vietnam this is not
totally
out of keeping with some of the things
my mother says McCarthy is she's no
longer with us so I don't know how she'd
feel about now but she said McCarthyism
was the most danger it was the most
dangerous and disturbing thing she ever
lived through right
um in the history of her long life and
she lived about a century
for about a century so um died Just As
Trump got elected
um and it seems like there's something
completely legitimate about people's
feelings that the government is not
responsive to their needs right I mean
people on the left and the right this
sort of a
cross-polarization thing but it it is
certainly too simplistic but is part of
the problem just that the institutions
that we deal with on a daily basis are
just so big that individuals are ignored
by them on a regular basis
well I think that is part of it I mean
your bureaucracy should not be
underplayed here as having a role and
even though the bureaucracy in principle
is
in principle is treating people fairly
somehow being treated as exactly the
same and I mean the bureaucracy is not
competent these days when you know it
can't we've got we've got so many
regulations that have divided the
bureaucracy
so I mean again I'll give you a silly
example I just finished running the
center where Henry Farrell is currently
a fellow the center for study and
Behavioral Studies
and
um we're doing construction project up
there the first construction project
since the place was built
one day I come there and the road
leading up to the center is being redone
we're about to have big trucks going
down the road and up the road this is
all being that this is all under the
supervision of Stanford
one piece of the bureaucracy wasn't
talking to another piece of the
bureaucracy right
and just take that to the level of a
country
right how many times have we run into
you know one regulator saying one thing
and another regulator saying another
thing and they're both right within
their narrow thing but they're not
talking to each other
um
if you think about someone I very much
admire is a woman named Hillary codham
c-o-t-t-a-m she's currently uh
a fellow at new America but she's an
important designer and player in Britain
and she's basically trying to build an
alternative to the current welfare state
okay in which in the current welfare
state you're a poor family let's say
some of your members are dysfunctional
they're alcoholic or they're addicted
some are truant
uh some are disabled
some are unemployed
some are breaking the laws you have
different people coming in to the same
person with each of those different
things so you might have 10 people or 20
people
coming into this family and they're not
talking to each other
so her idea is to and therefore you lose
all trust in government
one person's telling you one thing one
person's telling you something else one
person's not paying any attention
whatsoever
um or can't provide the kind of help you
need so she's trying to create a system
that is actually starts with the family
and what it needs or a unit and what it
needs and then building a bureaucracy or
a set of carers
who respond to that as opposed to them
so the police works with the social
worker not separately
and that's that's an indication of what
I think your question originally was
that we've lost confidence in the
competence here of government not
because the individuals aren't
necessarily competent but because the
system has proven itself unwieldy
and not really delivering what we
fundamentally need
and even though it does give us certain
things I mean we're not living in
the pre-governmental world sure but also
we're not even only living in the
government world right there's all these
different Interlocking Systems that
affect our lives that's right just
before we started doing this recording
of the podcast I had a moment of abject
fear because my internet seemed to be
out I thought I was going to be in
trouble but also I felt a little bit
powerless it turns out it was my
computer's fault not Verizon's fault but
you know we and probably maybe I'm
guessing people don't even distinguish
between the faceless bureaucratic nature
of the internet company and the
healthcare provider and the government
and the police it's all something
against which their individual needs
seem to sort of you know rattle
helplessly against and so well I do
think they sometimes distinguish the
police from the others at least in
countries where police carry guns
um I think that's the one they can
distinguish
um
no but that that's absolutely true
there's a merger of all that one of my
graduate students from a long time ago
Audrey Sachs who's now at the World Bank
her dissertation work was trying to find
out in Zambia whether the aid that
people were getting whether they
attributed it to the government who made
the roads possible and brought the Gates
Foundation or whoever in or whether they
attributed it to the Gates Foundation
um you know how much credit does
government get for the things that it
makes possible
and it wasn't that much wasn't that that
much huh okay well okay I mean let's
take a little bit more because this is I
think that I've been shortchanging a lot
of what you're currently working on
which is about making things better
right and and you do you put a lot of
thought into how do we get people to
recoup or recover that sense of shared
fate toward the future I mean maybe you
can say a little bit about how we can we
can try to get back to that state where
we're all in the same boat or I don't
know whether getting back is the right
formulation but you know what I mean
yeah I'm not sure getting back is and
there are cases where there have been
well I mean we all have so the term that
John Alquist and I used was community of
Fate f-a-t-e not Faith but the
interlinking of people and subsequently
I expanded that to say inclusive and
encompassing
um community of Fate so that we're
talking
more broadly because if you think about
it all of us almost all of us unless
we're Psychopaths or sociopaths uh live
in some kind of Community of Faith it
may just be our immediate family
um it may be our uh religious community
it may be an ethnic community
um but many of us live in situations
where we feel responsible to people who
are not our immediate relatives
um and hope that they feel some
obligation to us and that can be
Community created
I'm interested in how to replicate that
in places where it doesn't exist and how
to expand it
um so that it's not just I will help
someone who looks like me or sounds like
me or lives next door to me but will
even consider making significant
sacrifices in some cases
for far distant others who can never
reciprocate but who are deserving of my
care and attention
and what this is again where empirical
and normative interact back to the
original issue so my question my nor you
know I'm interested in trying to create
these kinds of communities and I'm
interested those are that's a normative
concern I'm interested in how to evoke
from people that part of themselves
which is pro-social and not just
privately self-interested because I
recognize both of our both are in us and
there are times when my survival might
take precedence over everything else I
get it
[Music]
um
but I'm interested in where we can evoke
from people that pro-social behavior
um what we were talking about in a way
about the representatives actually
acting in the public good
not just in their private interest or
just in the interest of a narrow set of
citizens
and I found that the answer we John
Alquist and I studied some labor unions
that had succeeded in doing this as well
as some that had not done that but were
in the same
sector attracted the same kind of
workers so these were transport sector
unions they were Longshore workers and
truck drivers in the United States and
Australia
so basically the same kind of people
um and they were all heterogeneous
politically we could document that I
mean they weren't all Republicans they
weren't all Democrats they weren't all
radicals they weren't all radicals on
the writer radicals on the left
um they were a mixture
and yet one set of organizations was
able to evoke these kinds of commitments
and another set of organizations or not
and it really came back to a set of
government Arrangements that were
created in whatever the crucial
constitutional moment for that Union was
and a kind of leadership that was
committed to sustaining that so the
governance Arrangements that evoke
pro-social Behavior
involve a rank and file democracy the
the workers actually vote on the
contracts directly and they
um vote and discuss all kinds of things
it required uh socialization so they
learn the norm that you fight for what
you believe in you sometimes lose you
sometimes win but you go on and discuss
it again another day that becomes an
important Norm
it required socialization in terms of
Education about the world
not just about these Norms but what the
world actually looks like and what's
actually happening in the world so that
if you came to if some leadership came
or even some members came to the rank
and file and said see those ships over
there they're in Australia and Sydney
they're loading ammunition
um for the Dutch to put down the
rebellion in Indonesia
and the workers could say
they could have the reaction which many
of them did right off the bat that's not
fair Dinkum we can't allow that to
happen you know people have a right to
Rebel yeah others could say are you sure
proved to me that that those are that's
ammunition that that's going into a
Dutch ship and that that ship is going
to Indonesia to put down a rebellion
so that required a discussion in which
they had to really evaluate the kind of
information they were getting and come
to some kind of collective understanding
of it by arguing with each other now
they'd already created some Community
for a basis to do that by the
socialization of norms by working
together and other things which are
definitely an advantage over starting
sui generis but not in Super Bowl things
I mean we can create circumstances where
people's kids go to school together
where people work together where people
play together where people form
communities around all kinds of things
we know that they do that soccer clubs
um right
so and then to actually create
circumstances where they were taking a
vote and putting something on the line
um some kind of sacrifice giving up a
day's work because and therefore pay
possibly facing going to jail
um
something on the line that uh for this
action and they could be if they could
feel efficacious in this case and that's
the trickiest part actually about how to
scale this because these were
longshoremen
or truck workers who could actually stop
something from happening they could not
load they had something or unload cargo
most of us can't find that point of
Leverage
so that's the sort of next thing that
I'm working on is where are those points
of Leverage how do you create those
communities or the basis for those
communities so that people will begin to
talk to each other they'll come into the
room and have that constitutional debate
without tearing each other apart how do
you create enough of a structure around
that so that they can do that and then
how do you give them something where
they can feel that they've been
efficacious that by acting they've done
something now what I find remarkable in
this contemporary world is what some of
the kids have done around climate change
some of those
and they're I mean they don't feel like
they've won
but they certainly feel like by
mobilizing by shutting down schools at
times by doing things that they're
acting and that they're getting
beginning to get hurt that they're
beginning to get recognized and that's a
form of efficacy
so I think there are ways to do this and
I you know Hari Han who you mentioned
earlier is someone who thinks a lot
about these issues Marshall Gans it's
people who come out of the social
movement
sort of background or literature who
really want to think about what's the
next step here we want to get beyond the
social movement the Arab Spring that
erupts and dies but how do you actually
create that expanded and inclusive
community of Fate that is able to
sustain itself and is willing to
really evoke from people pro-social
behavior when it's important to engage
in pro-social Behavior which is not all
the time this is not about being
self-sacrificial every moment of your
day and night this is not being a martyr
and I think some of those things you
just said just instantly make sense like
if you're experiencing different kinds
of people and different kinds of
Lifestyles maybe you get to humanize
them amongst yourselves a little bit
more but but the one that I really liked
is the idea that when you do if I tell
me if I'm misrepresenting this but when
you do something for somebody else or
for another group you become more
invested in their success it's not when
they do something for you that you you
feel you owe them then then you start
feeling resentful but when you give them
something you want them to do better I
love that idea and and that that sounds
like something we should figure out
institutions to make that happen a lot
more
and the way we saw that first was
actually empirically was so the very
first actions that the Longshore workers
on the west coast of the U.S did of this
sort and the Australian Longshore
workers did was in response to the
Chinese communities in the cities like
San Francisco and Sydney and Melbourne
who came to the longshoreman and said
look what the Japanese this was the
1930s look what the Japanese are doing
to Manchuria and to the peasants in
venturia those are our brothers and
sisters and the Longshore said who have
a
a slogan
um oh an injury to one is an injury to
all
an injury to one is an injury to all so
when the Chinese came to the Longshore
workers and said those are our brothers
and our sisters
um the Longshore worker said there are
brothers and sisters too even though
we'll never meet them and they can never
do anything for us and we probably never
even have a meal at their house
but you know an injury to one is an
injury to all if it could happen to them
it could happen to us and we've so there
were two motivations one you feel better
by doing something but also you feel
like you're protecting your own world
and what you value in your own world if
you act on behalf of others whose worlds
are under threat
I mean I want this to happen it sounds
maybe a little bit utopian uh is what
are you talking but this is a proof of
it happened right I mean this these are
groups that actually did it and they
continue to do it and they've survived
for over 80 years with an organizational
framework that looks like this despite
technological change so it's the proof
of the possible not the proof that it
will be possible but the proof that it
can be done
and is it completely is it is it a very
unfair question to say could we apply
that kind of reasoning to polarization
in the United States between very uh Q
Anon people and you know the wokest
folks out there
I would like to believe so but I'm not
sure there may be some people I mean
there needs to be some some level of
willingness to have a conversation right
so that I think the Q the locustness I
don't know if they're willing to have a
conversation some are some aren't the Q
Anon not at all as far as we can tell
so I think there is you know there have
been times in this country and other
countries where there's been some
minority sometimes a significant
minority that will hear no reason
and you just have to live with it don't
worry about that and try to continue
I don't mean kill the people off I mean
but try to contain the damage that they
can do good okay but then for the 80 in
between the extremes
um again unfair question but is it are
there institutional changes that rather
than just you know being Kumbaya and
let's all get together can we change the
system in such a way as to get those
people into mutual
um
uh dependency I guess helping each other
I think there are I mean and I think
it's around
um probably starting
I mean there may be ways to do it big
but probably starting around things that
are smaller either smaller issues or
smaller organizations
um where
people
um already share some common interests
see the problem may have different
solutions so I'm thinking about
um
schools right you know right now the
schools are a place of yelling and
screaming by parents against each other
and against school boards but one could
imagine
re-jiggering all of that institutionally
so that you're allowing a lot of
different voices to be heard in a
sensible way and not allowing one group
to take control I mean that there that
would have to be blocked
um so that you could continue to hear
obviously things that are totally out of
bounds would have to be totally out of
bounds things that are illegal or
totally racist or whatever we always
have those delimitations on any
structure that we have
but we could find ways of reconstituting
some of these institutions that are
clearly not working in a way that begins
to evoke this kind of behavior and
attitude
I think this is a very good point like I
think I tend to err on the side of just
wanting to fix everything at once at the
highest level but I think you're you're
a more empirically grounded social
scientist than I am and pointing out
that oftentimes probably starting at the
small levels and letting things Bubble
Up might be a better strategy
well but there are also larger cases
where things might work so Marshall Gans
who I mentioned has been working with
mayors
um and in the United States and if you
think about the Mayors in the United
States they are incredibly diverse on
absolutely every Dimension you can think
of including what you just mentioned is
woken Q Anon right I mean you've got
you've got that in there too as well as
all the other kinds of ways in which
people can be different from each other
and he's able through a series of
strategies to get them to listen to each
other and to talk to each other
and I think that's another good starting
place now here's here's an organization
that already exists the organization and
Mayors here's something where there is
some common interest they're all coming
to these meetings
but they need to find a way to have a
conversation with each other across
these boundaries
and there are strategies to enable them
to begin to have that conversation and
then you build from there
and you're not going to achieve
everything because there are going to be
let's not forget there will be real
policy differences
so you can't expect to there will never
be a kambaya moment politics is about
conflict and controversy that's what
it's about and people trying to wield
power over each other
it is and I'm a big fan of not
forgetting the substantive policy
differences uh there are certain
attempts at new political parties that
seem to want to paper over that and I
think it's important to keep them in
mind but I mean maybe as the as the very
final question I'll ask something
completely different
um because you mentioned in the Memoir
article and elsewhere
your willingness to think about the
biggest problems within these fears that
you are working on uh
is how unusual is that are there enough
people thinking about the big problem
should we be encouraging more people to
think about the big problems and and or
does it make sense to put our efforts
into thinking at this biggest scale
complicated question because at one
level there are lots of people thinking
about the big problems but they're doing
in a sort of op-ed kind of way from my
perspective or popular books
um TED talks not that I haven't given a
TED talk but
um
you know but it's it's a different way
of going about taking
a big problem on and then there are
people who are rigorous Scholars who are
trying to address big problems using the
best tools of the trade and
often what I mean by taking on a big
problem is addressing a big problem but
getting at it
through so to understand how citizens
and governments get along I look at a
series of case and under what conditions
there will be compliance consent dissent
I look at a series of case studies of
conscription of of military service of
Taxation
a very concrete things to understand how
you evoke social behavior a big question
I you parse it by looking at an
organization which has succeeded in
doing it and contrasting it with
organizations that are quite similar but
made different choices at different
parts of the path
so my way of looking at a big problem is
through often through a series of small
bits of the big problem that then get
married together and I'm not alone in
that
um though different people have
different strategies of how to do it
um
what
distinguishes me is my from the rational
Choice group that I emerged from was
that I was willing to admit that these
were the big problems I wasn't just
trying to find out why
you know people complied with taxes in
this part of ancient Rome in these years
but really how it spoke to the larger
question of when people will comply with
or
avoid or actually get engaged in tax
revolts
um in response to the extractions of
government
collectors okay yeah uh I mean look it
sounds like a very good point I bet that
there's plenty of academics who assume
that once you start thinking about big
problems you've moved into the realm of
Ted talkers and pundits and away from
serious Academia but by keeping yourself
grounded in the specifics might be a way
to you know really make progress on the
big problems through rigorous work
number of people who do that I mean I am
not alone in that no I don't think so
but you're definitely a good example of
it and I like to end on an optimistic
note so I think that's a very good place
to do it Margaret Levy thanks so much
for being on the mindscape podcast
thank you it's been a pleasure
[Music]